now to Capitol Hill where after six
votes as I said we still still don't
have a speaker of the house here's Kevin
McCarthy moments after the house
adjourned tonight
I I felt as though we had a very good
discussion okay
well I think I think what I think what
you should engage being able to do that
vote that the discussions are going well
and continue but that doesn't mean
they're done
joining me now is Newt Gingrich former
speaker of the house and Fox News
contributor uh note I read somewhere
today I should remember where it is but
I don't because I've been reading a lot
um that there was the idea floated which
might have stirred this latest progress
in the negotiations that McCarthy at
some point might say okay forget about
this we're going to form some type of
Coalition with some Democrats and start
moving things along have you heard any
of that
no no and I don't think that Kevin would
do that uh you know McCarthy is a very
solid conservative his commitment to
America was very solidly conservative uh
the rules changes he'd already proposed
were very solidly conservative there's
no Common Ground uh and if you give the
Democrats any sense of control they're
going to demand veto over the
investigations they're going to demand
veto over the committee structures it's
not possible so I think McCarthy's
decided he's going to wear down and work
with the 20 members who have been
hostile I noted that the motion to
adjourn all but four of them voted with
the conference only four of them voted
against the Republican conference on the
motion to adjourn and I think that's a
good sign I've been told all day from
various phone calls that a lot of the
members are now looking for a way to
come back together they want some
concessions most of the things they want
are relatively reasonable and that's
part of the legislative process as you
pointed out earlier I did a tweet today
saying it's really hard to explain uh to
Putin or Xi Jinping or Kim Jong-un
exactly what's going on because this is
freedom and freedom is messy and sloppy
and also uh remarkable remarkably
creative will get there and we'll have a
speaker probably I think probably
sometime tomorrow and I just checked a
few minutes ago the last time this
happened in 1923 it took nine ballots
and the following election the
Republicans picked up 22 more seats so
people shouldn't assume this is the end
of the Republican party in any way this
is a healthy tough serious conversation
and I think probably by sometime
tomorrow virtually all not all but
virtually all of the conference will
have found a way to come back together
just so you understand what I was saying
nude I wasn't saying that Kevin McCarthy
was actually going to do that
but the possibility of that happening
obviously that if that ever did come to
fruition after 25 ballots
there would be one group that would be
blamed for that and at that point it
wouldn't be Kevin McCarthy that's all
I'm saying so that may have been a
little bit of a carrot to get things to
to move that's all I was saying there
are no there are some people you know
Congressman Don Bacon of Nebraska has
been very open that if the hardliners
who are anti-mccarthy stay tough enough
that he would in fact reach out to try
to work something out just purely just
to try to prove to people you can't have
10 percent of the conference dictate to
90 percent of the conference I mean
Lincoln warned in his first inaugural in
1861 the problem with secession as a
principle is once you get to secede so
does everybody else get to succeed well
that's the problem that these guys have
now created they basically have said
look any five Republicans can decide to
Blackmail the conference and I think
that's going to be totally unacceptable
as a way of going forward and it would
make the house ungovernable and betray
pray the trust of the American people
remember we got almost three million
more votes than the Democrats did for
the house and those folks voted for us
to have some kind of effective system
not to spend all the next two years in
chaos I don't think many many people
campaigned on this spectacle we've seen
over the past two days by the way
President Biden reacted to all of this
Newt uh and this was his take on this
be able to have a Congress that can't
function is just embarrassing and we've
had a lot of trouble with the attacks on
our institutions already
and uh it just that that's what worries
me more than anything else
wait wait no this is an attack on the
institutions I mean this man says that
that's embarrassing I mean he
embarrasses us every day sorry about
that that's mean but
no look I think the idea that Joe Biden
who has been lying consistently about
his son who's gotten Rich by means that
I think are probably illegal who has
never been been to the border and is now
I think going to finally have a visit
next week uh you look at his policies
you look at his weakness around the
world I don't think we need to be
lectured by Joe Biden this is a healthy
free Republican party we're not the
Nancy Pelosi machine we don't have the
culture of the Democrats we're not a
collection of musk ox who get LED around
by our nose and that's part of the
nature of being Republican if you want
to be an independent free-thinking
person who has to get up and argue your
case you ought to be Republican if you
want to be part of a group that does all
you're told by a boss you ought to be a
Democrat all right now great to see you
tonight as always thanks so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else